- These kids can make the
hole thing on their phone,
put it on SoundCloud
and be eating lobster
with Drake in a week.
And that was actually truly the seed
which led to me investing
in Facebook and Twitter,
for me starting Wine Library TV.
This is a true story,
I don't tell it often.
- [Male] What is the most common complaint
you get in your DM's?
- It sits around,
most common complaint I get is.
(upbeat music)
One, two, three, (yelling).
This is Monday Night Raw
and Weekly Vee Nine.
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ Immortal, immortal, immortal ♪
- What up, vlog?
Pretty busy day.
All B-roll from what I'm
hearing on this Monday,
bunch of big clients are in,
executives from Bojangles,
the board I'm on.
If you're from the
Carolinas or the southeast
you know that incredible chain.
A telecom company's in town,
some new business stuff,
just a busy Monday,
nothing too crazy,
Weekly Vee, sports cards,
I've got the fever.
♪ Hey yeah ♪
♪ I be flying with the
angels, every day, yeah ♪
♪ I play this fool ♪
♪ Life is crazy, yeah ♪
♪ I work 60 hours a day man, yeah ♪
♪ I'm built to grind,
it's my escape plan ♪
♪ It's way deeper than the pavement ♪
♪ I play this fool without his gray hair ♪
- People's happiness declines after 30.
- That's stupid, that's a stupid study.
- Do you want to comment on it?
- It's stupid.
I don't care about reports,
I care about your individual thing.
There's happy as fuck 39-year-olds.
I'm happy as fuck at 44.
That's a generic study
that took a base of
certain thousands of people
and now people are like, oh, fuck,
I'm gonna be unhappy at 39.
You're not gonna be unhappy at 39.
You can be happy or
unhappy at one and at 100.
It's fucking mindset.
Do you have self esteem?
Do you actually have self esteem?
Are you actually in a mindset
where you can deal with
other people's judgment?
Fuck this report.
Focus on yourself.
♪ You think it's popping now ♪
♪ Just wait for what's on the way ♪
♪ We got some moves we trying to make ♪
♪ Made like 100,000
decisions just yesterday ♪
♪ While the message make
millions of decisions every day ♪
- [Female] My question would be
what's your advice for Pinterest
for a stay-at-home mom
that wants extra income?
- I think back to Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
I think when somebody wants extra income,
they go for the sale too quick.
So they look at Pinterest,
they understand as you know,
because you lead it for me,
it's not something I'm
spending a lot of time on,
but there's plenty of
other thought leaders
and users that are talking about it.
So somebody stumbles across that concept
the way I talk about
TikTok or other things
and says, yes, I want to do that.
And the problem is
because they want extra side hustle money,
like to save up for their Disneyland trip,
which is so amazing,
the problem is they
don't have the discipline
to build an actual community
to go in for the close.
So A, you could get lucky
and have a single pin that goes viral
that goes to your Shopify page
and sells your thing.
But the way to build in any
platform, including Pinterest,
is to put out a lot of
content that's just valuable
and may just come back
to your blog or your shop
without going in for that hard sell.
In essence, romance.
The odds of rolling up on somebody
and being like, do you want
to go into my hotel room
at the bar?
Low.
Romance for a couple months works.
And so its about putting out content
that brings value,
whether that comes in video form,
whether that's infographics.
It leads to self-awareness.
How do you actually make good content?
Are you a good photographer?
Can you draw?
Can you make a video?
'Cause that all plays on Pinterest.
And that works on Pinterest
and it works everywhere else.
Self-awareness of how to create,
patience, romance, to create a community,
which then allows you to go in for the ask
after you've built up the equity.
The best way to make a little side hustle
as a stay-at-home mom on Pinterest
is to think about
cashing in nine months in
not nine minutes in.
♪ No one taught me ♪
♪ I was like damn ♪
♪ Fuck did I do it myself ♪
♪ No one put me on then ♪
♪ Fuck it, I'll do it myself ♪
♪ Everyone's scared to go talk to her ♪
♪ Everyone's scared to be number one ♪
♪ Fuck it, I'll do it myself ♪
♪ Better cash out every month of coats ♪
♪ I've been on this ♪
(yelling)
(intense music)
He's a beast.
I can take him.
(crowd yelling)
- One, two, three. (yelling)
I told you, I told you,
I told you!
Told you!
- [Brock] Where you all at now?
- I was with you the whole time.
I was with you the whole time.
She's the ref.
And her iPhone is charged.
("Real Slime" by Lil Keed)
- All right, big day today, Monday,
did a ton of meetings,
most of it was B-rolled,
bought a ton of fucking sports cards.
Then I went to Barclays Center
for a little WWE,
big shout out to Hunter Hurst,
appreciate the hospitality
and going at it tomorrow.
AJ and I got into tech
because I read an article in a magazine
that I picked up on a trip to Napa,
a magazine called Business 2.0.
This is a true story.
I don't tell it often,
I literally pick up,
I'm at the airport,
I'm in the wine business.
- [Male] Reading magazines
doesn't scream tech.
- Yeah, this was, when were
you a freshman in college?
- This is '05, '06.
- Yep, it was '05.
I'm in Napa.
We're in the tech business
because, let me rephrase,
I'm innovating in the wine business
because I have a website and I do email
and I'm buying Google Ad Words,
people have heard that before
but I pick up a magazine
'cause my flight was delayed
and literally read it,
like read this Business 2.0
and it was about domain names.
Like fish.com is $48 million.
I'm like what?
And it was less about that hyperbole,
like sports cards,
it was more about
there was something that
just clicked in my chemicals
and when I landed,
I called AJ,
I called AJ at a Friday
night or a Saturday,
he was at his like first
college party or second,
it was definitely first month.
- No, it was the first one.
- And I'm like bro,
I'm like you need to leave the party.
He's like, all right,
I'm gonna go outside.
- [Male] In the middle
of doing a keg stand.
- Whatever he was up to.
- Not quite but yeah.
- Plotting.
And so like I literally am like,
I'm gonna change your life.
This is literally what
the opening line was.
I'm like I think I see something.
- This is like my third day in college.
- And he's like, all right, bro,
talk to you tomorrow.
But no, we actually it was great,
we had like a 15 minute call.
- Longer, way longer.
I was outside of a frat house
for like an hour and a
half in the freezing cold.
- Is that true?
- Yeah.
- And that was actually truly the seed
which led to me investing
in Facebook and Twitter,
for me starting Wine Library TV,
AJ started Jets,
AJ's the first vlogger in the family.
He started Jets TV
a couple months before Wine Library TV
in his dorm room.
It was the seed
and I almost even in
telling you this story
feel like we're gonna be at the combine
or at the senior bowl
or at the draft
or it's gonna be a Tuesday afternoon
and I feel like we're
one conversation away
from innovating in the
sports business arena
in a way that transcends it.
I believe that to be true.
We just need one second.
Everybody we're competing with
needs to be perfect for 12 rounds.
We literally need one conversation
to win in business.
Right now, we're trying
to impact young men's life
for a legacy
and AJ's striving for happiness
and I'm macro fucking,
I'm creating macro air cover
for whatever the fuck
we want to do forever.
(upbeat music)
♪ Don't forget the rest of me ♪
♪ She always takes the best of me ♪
♪ And says she wants the best for me but ♪
- What's up, guys?
Jason.
We are at Hunt and Fish Club with Alex,
my buddy Crispy,
he's not paying attention.
We're waiting for Gary.
He's finishing up a meeting
and then we're gonna
hopefully film the intro
to Weekly Vee Eight.
That's about it.
We're waiting on Gary.
Let's go.
How you been feeling about the vlog?
We haven't really talked about it.
- Good.
- I think it's, I don't know,
I'm really heavy on like
the Twitter feedback,
like where I wasn't on Daily Vee and--
- I mean people are really loving it.
- Yeah, and a lot of people,
it doesn't show in the analytics as much
but a lot of people are
watching it on TVs too.
People are really treating it as a show.
- [Gary] I think that's right,
I think that's right.
I'm really happy with it.
- It's been fun.
- Are you enjoying it?
- [Jason] I am.
- Are we experimenting enough?
- [Jason] I'm trying to do more.
I want to do more.
I want to do an episode
where like Raghav narrates the whole thing
and it's like the vlog
where you're doing your thing.
- [Gary] I'll watch two
or three of the last ones
this weekend but I think we
need to experiment a lot more.
I feel like that's a strength of mine
that I need to always push everyone for.
So I'll try to get a read on it.
What's up, bro?
- How you doing, man?
- Good man, how are you?
- Good, good, good.
What's good, bro?
How are you?
- Not bad, not bad.
- Good man, thank you.
What's up, bro?
Thanks for the love.
- Yeah of course.
- I appreciate that.
Thank you for saying what's up.
How are you man?
Really good, how are you?
- Hey brother.
- How are you?
- I'm good man.
- Thank you
for the love, guys.
- You just text me, man.
- I literally just
wrote that fucking text.
All right, photo?
- [Guys] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Who's taking it?
Thank you so much, man.
Thank you for what you do for us.
I appreciate that.
- Keep motivating us, man,
keep motivating us.
- Nice to meet you.
- How you doing, man?
- [Gary] Gary, real
pleasure, brother, thank you.
Okay, what do you need?
- [Jason] I want to do like a one-liner,
like two sentences on like
how to block out judgment.
Can I get you on the side of the road
like right here?
- Do you want to go there
and I'll walk towards you?
- That'd be dope.
- Yeah go.
Just like blocking out the nose
in the chaos of Times Square,
you need to block out the nose
of the judgment your mother, your father,
the cynicism, block it out.
You can't hear it.
Do you understand?
You can't fucking hear it.
♪ Y'all be on some hard shit ♪
♪ I just spilled my yard shit ♪
♪ Focus on the money, not days ♪
♪ Probably flat, I just gonna flaunt it ♪
- [Male] I like, you posted
something a couple weeks ago
that said something about,
I don't remember the exact quote,
like your Instagram isn't your portfolio.
- Oh, the art gallery,
like the way I did that?
- [Male] Yeah, that's what it was.
I like that.
- I have all these people that are like,
no Gary, I can't post that
because it's gonna fuck up,
nobody gives a fuck about your fucking,
they look in the feed.
I'm not going to your account be like,
oh, it's aesthetically
pleasing, you're fresh.
You know why?
Everybody's fucking worried about them.
I'm worried about putting
out shit that helps.
Every post, why I win is
I sit there and I'm like
why would this be good for you?
Not why does this make me look good?
Every single post that I see,
99% of it comes from one filter,
how is this gonna make me look good?
I'm with this cool person,
I'm with this hot good looking person,
I've got this new thing,
I'm in this fancy thing,
I'm at Coachella rolling loud, courtside,
how does this make me look good?
What the fuck value is
that bringing any of us?
And I'm starting to see
resentment start to build.
Just like the popular
kids in your high school
freshman year, you want to
be fucking friends with them.
By senior year, you're
like fuck those people.
That's what's happening on Instagram.
Those popular people on Instagram
better be real careful.
They're about 30 seconds away
from the thing turning on them.
That's great that you're
taking another fucking
selfie with a celebrity.
I'm real happy for you
that you're dating another model.
It's really cool that your
boyfriend bought you a new car.
Great private jet, dick,
great Valenciano, congrats fuck face.
The resentment's building, right?
What do you do,
can you imagine making a
video where you're like,
hey, if you're a kid watching this,
let me tell you what my uncle
taught me in fourth grade?
Where's that?
Bro, the number one person in the NBA
that goes up my list
is the guy who takes a photo,
makes a video tomorrow on Instagram
showing him trying to make a fucking thing
that we all do,
crumpled up paper and missing it
and being like, fuck,
and just like real.
Like that thing will go bananas.
You know how many of my friends,
like I have rich friends,
powerful friends,
outside of like the cool Gary Vee,
there's Gary Vaynerchuk
who rolls with real shit
and when they see me like
posting like sports cards
or like going garage saleing
they're like what the fuck are you doing?
And I'm like what I want dick,
you worry about yourself.
That's my answer.
I'm helping people.
You know how many people went,
people don't have money.
I read my comments.
They're like, cool, step
one, be rich, right?
They're like, cool, Gary Vee,
you tell me to invest
$1,000 into sports cards,
I don't have money.
I kept listening.
I'm like, oh okay, let
me show you what I did
when I had no money.
Take five dollars, go garage saleing
and make it 80.
Take 80 the next weekend and make it 130.
And the sports card thing
is gonna make kids rich.
I'm 'bout to make a
bunch of kids rich, rich.
(upbeat music)
And Marc, I think once people
start making the world
about happiness, not money,
then this is gonna make a lot more logic.
Because a lot of people go for it,
have a nice home in Summit,
New Jersey right now,
make 412 a year, life is good,
kids in private school, good shit,
Jersey Shore house, good shit, good shit
and they're gonna listen
to us to Jersey bozos
and they're gonna be like fuck it,
I'm unhappy I'm going for it
and the story for Hank
is it's actually gonna fail
because what Hank was was a number six,
he was a number six,
a great number six.
It's the Scotty Pippin thing.
Scotty Pippin is all-time
overrated in my opinion
because he had a great
all-time number one hiding it.
And when he went to Portland
and he went to Houston, no.
And by the way, Hank
right now at 412 a year
is listening to us and go for it,
let me just finish this thought
and I can see you want to jump in,
you have to go?
Oh, you have to go to the bathroom?
So go, I'll finish this.
Go take a pee.
So let me finish my thought.
One, I find it fascinating
that Marc couldn't hold it.
I just think that's all-time interesting
out of all the things.
Number two, on the Scotty Pippin thing,
and it's not to razz Scotty,
and of course, this is coming
from a Knicks fan who's bitter,
but Hank, if you're listening,
Marc's right, not because of the money
but because of the happiness
because if you're 44 and your life is good
but you hate your fucking job,
you hate it,
you really know you actually hate it,
but you like your life,
what you need to ask yourself
is do you like your life
because of the financial
things that are happening
and you look happy versus
actually being happy?
Because I can tell you
when you make that jump
and you fail,
and you have to have the shame,
and that's the word I'm gonna use,
the shame to move your
family out of Summit,
and move into another town
and you've got a 12 and a nine-year-old
who are now crying
'cause they're going to a different school
and they went from being fancy
to maybe less fancy.
That is a lot of carnage
that most people don't
have the stomach for.
The problem is that nobody tells you
is that at 72 years old
you spend the next 20 years
of your life in regret
'cause you weren't happy.
And that is not fucking easy.
And I don't say this lightly.
But when I hear Marc say, go for it,
I actually understand it
because I spend a lot more time
analyzing what 70 and
80 and 90-year-olds say
and I understand why a 44-year-old
doesn't have the strength
to disappoint their kids
or to look stupid in
front of their friends
or to confuse the world
and it's easier at 27,
even with a new kid,
than it is at 44,
which is why I love the internet.
Marc and I are byproducts,
we would be totally
different men in our careers
if the internet didn't come along.
If you listen to his stories,
Google and diapers and landing page
and $500 check and the pit,
we're the byproducts of our age
of the entrepreneurs that
had practical opportunity
on the internet
that would've never existed
if we were 40 years earlier.
That's what I want for
everybody to realize.
We understood that
and that's what we navigated on.
You can have a side hustle too.
So we talked about Hank quitting.
Let's talk about Hank,
instead of golfing for
four hours on Saturday,
let's talk about Hank
instead of coming home
and having a glass of wine
and watching the news,
The Daily Show or sports,
if you're really unhappy
with what you do for a living,
give me back those 14 hours
that you waste each week
and set up a landing page,
set up an Instagram
account around Star Trek
or soccer or sports cards.
Side hustle practicality with
patience where you build it
where Marc and Lev had to
look at each other and say
fuck, maybe there's something here now.
Notice what he did.
He did what I do.
Do shit and then let the market show you
there's something there
and then grow.
The time.
Brother, it's the weeds,
it's pulling the weeds.
Too many people are entitled
and don't want to waste their time
when their time ain't worth shit.
♪ Like the way she worked ♪
♪ She always puts me first ♪
♪ And I know I've been around ♪
♪ But I swear you got the best on Earth ♪
- [Dustin] What is the most
common complaint you get
in your DM's?
- The most common complaint I get
is around lack of patience, really,
like hey, Gary Vee, I've been
doing this for three months,
nothing's happened
or you told me to try things,
I've tried three things,
skiing, cooking, and garage saleing
and it doesn't work.
It's a game of looking for excuse
of why the practical advice isn't right.
Common complaint is I tried, see?
Literally half-assed efforts
as an excuse to not actually do it.
It's like doing one
push-up and being like, yo,
it doesn't fucking work.
- [Dustin] What's one piece of advice
you would tell every teenager today?
- I would tell every single
teenager in the world
that other people's opinions
are the biggest poison to their happiness
and that them worrying about
what the popular kids think,
them worrying about what
some of the random comments
in their TikTok or
Instagram are,
them worrying about
other people's opinions
is the easiest way to
continue to be unhappy
or how to build a
foundation of unhappiness
and how to get insular with themselves
and focus on themselves
and more importantly,
don't judge others,
which that then lets you not
have their judgment hit you,
that whole thematic.
- [Dustin] I know you were kind of like
naturally had that in you but
is there anything that you
realized when you were young?
- I think getting picked
on for not speaking English
was a huge help
because I somehow through
luck of DNA or circumstance,
got comfortable with being on the outside.
Everyone's so desperate
to be on the inside
and I got really happy on the outside.
You see where I'm going?
- [Dustin] Yeah, that's an
interesting way to put it.
I never thought of it like that.
- Yeah, I feel like I got
comfortable being an outsider,
immigrant, and don't forget,
very forgotten middle fact of my life,
when I was a kid growing up,
Russia was the evil empire.
My entire first kind of eight grades,
Russia was the actual enemy, terrorism.
And I was Russian.
It was a thing.
I was bad at school,
and so I just got very used
to being on the outside.
I ate weird food.
My friends would come
over and they're like,
what's that weird soup your mom's making?
I'm like it's borscht, bitch.
I got very comfortable on the outside.
I don't need other people's acceptance.
I need my own
and then that is deep fucking happiness.
- [Dustin] Did your
parents help you with that
or did you just figure
that out on your own?
- I think they helped me by loving me.
My mom loved me.
But she loved me so much
but she didn't coddle me.
This is why I talk
about perfectly parented
and circumstances.
I got love
but I got punished,
there were circumstances.
When I got out of line, she spanked me.
When I got bad grades, she punished me
but I was the best.
It was just like get your
shit together in school,
there's accountability.
There was no delusion.
I was on the outside.
I was on the fucking outside.
And I played in games
that were merit-based.
- Sports.
- And business.
You got it?
I liked sports and business
because no parent's opinion mattered.
Either I made $83 today
shoveling snow or I didn't.
Either I went three for four in baseball
and hit a game winning double or I didn't.
I love merit.
Nobody's opinion.
That's why I don't like the Olympics,
fuck the judges.
Cool, right?
That's why I've always had a
weird relationship with boxing.
I love it
'cause it's the ultimate
merit, mano o mano,
nowhere to fucking hide
but if one guy doesn't
knock the other guy out,
it goes to the judges.
- [Dustin] When that happens,
how do you feel about it?
- Frustrated, frustrated.
But that's real life too.
Life is about judges.
People do get fired
'cause their boss is bad at the judgment.
So there's acceptance.
I'm not crippled by
humans mistakes and issues
and shortcomings and hypocrisies.
I'm not crippled by it.
I recognize it,
I'm not in love with it,
but I'm not in this kind
of like we're fucked.
Too much optimism overlaid.
I'm like if you're
fucked, don't be a boxer.
To me, no matter what anybody says,
there's a counter of like
do something about it.
But America is, move.
Costa Rica's nice.
People want the excuse.
People are addicted to the excuses.
I lived in a family that
demonized complaining,
demonized it too much.
I think it led to not being
able to be vulnerable.
So everything in balance
but demonized complaining.
(chill music)
- Okay, I don't want to do makeup.
I do it 'cause I'm good at it
but it's not something that
I see myself pursuing it.
What I want to do
is I want to be an actress.
I know it's gonna happen for sure,
I just don't know how to
get my foot in the door.
And the people that I--
- Where do you live?
- Long Island.
- Would you move to California?
- If that's what it takes, I'll do it.
- That's what it takes.
- And then what?
- Then there's more
things that it'll take.
- But I don't know how to speak to.
- Well it's really funny,
do you know how many people
want to be a beauty influencer
with 252,000 followers
on Instagram?
- I know.
- Do you?
- Yeah.
- Okay, what did you do?
You just did.
People think they have
to go take a course,
people feel like they have
to go and have a connection.
You just did.
What you can also do
is do that again.
You can move to California,
you could go to auditions,
you can work in coworking spaces
and be around people
and stumble into people,
you can thoughtfully look
at every single person
who likes one of your photos
and look at their profile
and see if they work at CIA or WME.
You can do what you've already done
at your young age.
You did, which is why
you have what you have.
But because you put being an
actress on a mental pedestal,
you don't see it the same
way you do makeup artistry.
- Yeah, yeah 'cause I feel like I have--
- You understand?
How brilliant is that?
Are you like my God?
You're like this guy,
like I'm so thankful that I'm--
- He has answers to
everything, it's insane.
- I definitely don't,
yes I do.
- I said it
without all that passion.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I believe you.
I will literally stand
by and wait for that.
- Yes, I will, I'm moving.
I can move tomorrow.
I can move tonight.
- So move tomorrow.
Let's go.
You should leave here right now and move.
- Hold on, I took notes in
my head before you leave,
I have a nine to five
job as a receptionist
that I'm dying to leave from.
- Well good, you're moving to LA anyway.
- How do I make money?
- Easily, besides buying sports cards
and trading them,
I think you, good news,
there's a lot of receptionist jobs in LA.
- But I don't want to be a receptionist.
- No shit, but you have to move.
You don't want to be a
makeup influencer, you are,
you don't want to be a receptionist,
you want to be an actress.
You go and move to LA
and be a receptionist,
keep hustling your makeup artistry
'cause you might be able
to get some more funds
to make it sustainable
so that you're not at risk
to go take those auditions
and those networking
because the receptionist job
may get you fired
when you go to lunch at one o'clock
but what you're really
doing is an audition
and if you keep growing
your beauty business
and start DM'ing beauty brands,
you might make enough brand deals
to allow you to do that full time
instead of receptionist
until you get the actress job.
- Okay, I make money off of Instagram
but it's not consistent money.
- So go harder.
How many beauty brands
do you DM every night?
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
- Got it?
- Wait, wait,
can I take a picture with you?
- Yes.
- Please?
(upbeat music)
- What could Hershey's do?
I think that they should
get into meaningful chocolate extensions.
When you hear Hershey's,
you hear chocolate, right?
And so whether it's
direct-to-consumer chocolate shakes,
protein shakes, line extensions
where chocolate has permission.
I also would probably create
a super premium chocolate bar,
like a $25 Hershey's bar
that elevates the brand
which then makes kind
of their core products
seem like a good deal.
So that's what I would do with Hershey's.
Levi's I think really needs to
think about a couple things.
So what's funny about there's,
talk about an iconic brand with denim,
what I think Levi's should
consider is like really,
Levi's feels like the
brand that can really win
the first kind of smart pants game,
when your pants kind of tell you
you need to lose weight
'cause your waist is
connected to your phone.
I think the smartification of jeans
is gonna be a real business
and I think it's Levi's for the taking.
I think Supreme needs to be careful.
I think Supreme's extending its brand.
So it's funny,
Hershey's, I want them to extend it.
Supreme, I want them to be thoughtful
about where they extend it.
They're doing a ton of
JB's with other brands
and eventually, it
becomes a saturation play.
So they're a big business.
So I have a lot of empathy for that
but I would tighten that brand up
and be thoughtful about
where it's extending
because when you think
about brands like Playboy,
it extended its brand to everything
and eventually it didn't mean anything.
And so I think Supreme
needs to be very thoughtful,
especially 'cause it's cool
to not overextend their brand
to places that are not cool
that eventually makes them not cool.
Well, it's less about
what they should stick to,
it's just that no matter how much
a brand that's dorky pays them
they should not do JB's with them.
That's a good one, Medium.
So I should disclose
that I was an early investor in Medium.
Marc, legal likes that,
I'm sitting next to Marc.
You know, it's funny,
they've gone pay for content,
which I'm a buyer of.
I've been clicking,
I found myself in the last 12 months
clicking articles that I find on social
and then want to read them
and they're behind pay walls
and I haven't paid yet
but last week, there was an article
I really wanted to read and I was close
and I thought that was an
interesting chemical feeling
that I was close to
signing up for something
that I probably would never use again,
which meant that I was happy paying $108
to read that article
because it was nine dollars a month,
and I knew that I would never use it
and forget about it forever
and pay $108 a year
just to read this one sports article.
And so I think Medium has
that potential for sure
and I think original creative content,
think of Medium like Sirius.
If they can get some original writers
that only live in that environment,
their subscription product
can get really good.
And so that's what I think.
Twitter story testing, I love that.
I think every platform should
be in the stories business.
Ephemeral content works.
That's why it worked on Instagram,
that's why it's working on YouTube,
that's why it's working on Spotify
and if you're telling me right now
that Twitter's testing a stories product
that excites the shit out of me.
Everybody should be using stories
across all these platforms and LinkedIn,
it's just contextual to the
audience. business-centric or,
you know my take on LinkedIn,
it's starting to become more Facebook.
Stories is a function that
humans have told us we like.
We like that style of distribution.
Give me something
snackable that disappears,
I like that.
Oh, by the way, television
and newspapers and radio
were in stories format.
Only the internet sits there forever.
Everything else that we were consuming,
traditional media was
built on ephemeral content.
The news played and then it went away.
It didn't stick there forever.
So you would watch a TV show
and then later VHS came
and later DVR came.
So this is a human behavior.
We're super okay with consuming
content that goes away.
Just let me consume it in a
non-frictionless environment,
in a frictionless environment, excuse me,
and that's why I think
stories as a function
is going to become a
very meaningful genre,
and it already is
and it doesn't surprise
me that every platform
is building out their
"stories capability".
- All right, going into a MikMak meeting,
pop that up right there.
MikMak, I'm on the board of, company.
So we're not filming the board meeting.
So that means see ya, later, Dustin.
Operational, that's how we do it.
(upbeat music)
Yeah, and not only that,
you know why I'm so hyped
and putting out what I'm putting out,
if I had Instagram DM when I was 14,
there was no internet.
If you want to be a producer,
you can actually lay in your fucking bed
or sit on the bus,
first of all, thank you,
you've got the technology in your pocket,
not like you have to save up money
to get into the studio
or buy some janky ass shit, right?
- [Female] That's
literally what I do all day
is sit on my phone creating content.
- That's number one, yes.
That just gave me goosebumps,
that's how true it is.
I went to a school that
was 80% African American
and like low income,
it was a hood school
and everybody wanted to be a rapper.
And I watched my friends
have to sell fucking nickel bags or hustle
or fucking steal
just to get into the studio
one time for an hour.
Don't worry about it.
Don't even look at it anymore.
Now, these kids can make the
whole thing on their phone,
put it on SoundCloud
and be eating lobster
with Drake in a week.
- You're right, you're right.
- So like I just want them
to have that perspective.
It's never ever been
easier to live your dream.
You want to work in Hollywood?
You can lay down on your bed at night,
you can be on the bus
or the subway doing it.
You can DM every single person
and one out of 813 of them replies
and says, I love your spirit,
come and be an intern.
- There it is.
It's real, the internet is real
and I don't want to, listen,
do I believe the system's rigged?
Yes.
Do I believe there's suppression?
Do I believe in circumstance?
But my big thing,
I told this kid long
ago and I use it a lot,
I'm like look,
this kid's situation was rugged.
Mom dead, dad fucked up, bad,
and I remember it was like a tough one,
it was like in real life,
not on the internet,
before even all this Gary
Vee shit, I was like listen,
please listen, I'm like
if one person in the world
ever came out of your situation,
then you can too.
And he rattled off six people
that came from his spot and his situation.
I just need people to remember that.
What happened is whatever reason,
we had the right mentality
through either parenting or circumstance
or just natural DNA
that let us look at adversity
as a springboard to success
and a lot of other people are insecure
and take adversity as what folds them.
And that's why I'm putting
out so much content
to try to build up their self esteem.
- Makes sense.
- Right?
- The reason you did that was
you weren't scared of no.
The people that are fancy,
they're like, Gary Vee,
but my time is worth something.
I'm like you know who
values their time the most,
the people that are doing the least.
I have all these people saying,
Gary Vee, that's some
bullshit, I value my time,
I should get paid what I deserve.
I'm like I do so much
free shit always forever
and by the way, Sam, my
time's worth more than yours.
People acting like their time,
how's your time worth something
when nobody's paying you for it?
I ain't doing that video for free.
They should pay me.
I'm like well, why aren't they?
The market told you they don't want you.
(laughs)
Right?
I'm like there are 74
million other video makers.
Sorry.
- I was saying that just the other day.
I was giving out B for free
just to get going.
- Of course and now some 20-year-old
thinks you gotta pay--
- You gotta pay 'em a whole lot of money.
- For what?
Nobody's ever heard of you.
Is your beat fresh?
And even if it's not,
beats is an arbitrage of fame.
People pay 'cause they're gonna say
oh, it was produced by him?
Oh, you're asking for a favor.
Every producer, the DJ
and the MC thing switched.
A lot of these kids aren't
historians of hip hop.
The MC was the supporter of the DJ.
It flipped.
So I don't know what audacious
table you're standing on
but if you get fucking
DaBaby to use your beat,
he's doing you a fucking favor.
I'd pay DaBaby.
- You gotta pay him to do it.
- If I was a producer,
I'd pay Meg the Stallion,
I'd pay DaBaby.
And hope they think it was fucking hot.
(upbeat music)
I'd be DM'ing them with like, here's me
and what's your PayPal?
♪ Out on my own ♪
♪ I could never make it ♪
- [Male] You talk about balancing
being your biggest fan and being humble.
How do you balance those two or manage it?
- By recognizing you can
have opposite feelings.
Everyone's so scared of
like I'm a contradiction.
No, you feel different things,
like the reality is is like
staying humble comes natural to me.
I don't want to big time anybody.
No matter how much I accomplish,
it's not interesting to me
to impose my success on somebody
in our human interactions.
That doesn't mean that
that's a contradiction.
Ironically, me saying you
can have a contradiction.
I think they think,
you think it's a contradiction
of having wild conviction and confidence
and being humble.
I don't.
I see them in a layered way.
I understand why people think,
even I set it up as a contradiction.
It's just not.
They're two easy feelings to bounce.
I live it, I know it's true.
I have the most fucking
confidence that I can win
and I also have no interest
of imposing my abilities on you.
The contradiction to confidence
is self doubt, not humility.
Humility's just kind.
Cool, you're welcome.
- [Female] I heard you say that.
- Right?
Yeah, it's just nice.
Yes, I know that I've been
successful in my profession
and people admire you.
What, am I supposed to
make you feel less than me?
It's so stupid.
You would grow a better beard than me.
I think that's where
the humility comes in.
It's like cool, yes, I'm good at this
and there are many things
you're better at than me
and yes, I understand
that we're in the moment
where what I do is cool.
Sports cards is cool.
I also remember when it was
the dorkiest dork shit of dork.
- [Male] Thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Male] So G, I found this quote,
when you were with Chris Bosch.
You said, "I believe 95% of the shit I do
"is based on what I learned
"in the trenches of sports card shows."
- Wow.
What are those things?
- [Male] Well can you talk to like
the opportunity in sports cards
is also you learning
to be an entrepreneur?
- Yeah, and it's not just sports cards,
it's also sneaker flipping.
It's why I think all
these sneaker flippers
are about to come and
dominate sports cards.
I'm actually gonna take a photo of this.
I think it's the same game.
This is me making content.
This is the same game,
this and this, same game, this and this.
This and this, it's the same game.
So I just think it's the same game.
It's called supply and demand.
It's called having courage to say no
when a grown up offers you less money
than you want for a card.
When I was 14
and some old man comes
to my table and says,
"How much you want for that Bo Jackson?"
I'm like, "Eight."
And they're like, "I'll give you five."
I'm like, "No, eight."
"Five."
"Eight."
Learning that versus the
friends that I did shows with
when the guy said, "I'll give you five"
and they're like, "I'll take it for four."
That's learning.
That, that, figuring out
that this Don Russ set
that was in Canada,
some kid walks around a show in 1992
and has Burger King,
Don Russ baseball packs
and he's like, would you buy
this, would you buy this?
And everyone's laughing at him.
I could hear it 'cause I'm watching,
right, that's what I do?
And I'm like who's that
kid and what's he selling
and what is that?
And he gets to me, he's like,
"Hey, you want these
Burger King Don Russ cards
"like from Canada?"
And I'm like, "I'll take 'em all."
Took a huge risk, bought 'em all,
priced 'em super expensive.
Everyone's like what the fuck?
I'm like, these are rare 'cause they were.
This is pre-internet.
There's no fucking Canadian
Burger King fucking cards
made from Don Russ.
Next thing you know, other
dealers are buying off me.
They were like the hit of the whole show.
I learned that when there's
a scarcity of something,
if you can build awareness of it
and if you believe that to be true,
not like you're a scam artist,
so I learned a ton,
how to negotiate with grown-ups,
how to see market dynamics,
how to price, how to set up my table,
why do I put the Luka,
if Luka's the hottest right now,
I realized that if I put
Luka in the top left corner
because the Luka and Lamar
are the hottest cards I have,
that that would work
because that's how people read pages,
they start at the top left.
And so it made people stop at my table.
So I was watching,
over time, I watched humans
and realized I was stopping more people
at my table than other tables
'cause I was putting the hottest cards
in the top left corner
because that's how people read pages.
I learned.
Why do you think my content does well?
'Cause I knew where to put the Luka's.
That's it.
You got it.
- [Danielle] Get an outro?
- Yes.
So I think this was really cool.
Danielle, I think you should
end the entire episode
with what just happened
here in the last 20 minutes.
There's so much that just happened.
Good week, they all are.
(fun upbeat music)
- Cards.
- Fuck this report, focus on yourself.
(laughing)
That was the truth.
- I know.
- [Drock] That's what we wanted.
- Yep, yep.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yep, yep, yep, love.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Hey guys, it's Gary.
This is Marc's first TikTok.
What is the most iconic
thing you're gonna say now
that we look back in 13 years
and look back and say, wow?
- Jets, J-E-T-S.
- My man.
That was perfect.
- Total pandering.
(quirky music)
- 2015, that's fun.
By the way, my eyes are going.
This is crazy sad news wine club,
I think I'm literally like 18 months away
from like glasses
which is nuts 'cause I had
laser, laser vision, sucks.
I'm pissed, sorry.
(dinging)
- Hey.
That's what I wake up to.
(laughing)
That's me talking to my
sleep when I wake up.
You didn't do Faily Vee this week.
- There was a lot of hate on that.
I did one clip,
I only had one
so I didn't brand it.
- [Gary] You should've just told 'em.
- [Jason] I know.
- Are you buying baseball cards?
- [Male] Yes.
- [Male] Theme of the day.
- The day?
This is the theme of the fucking year.
If you're not buying sports cards,
you're making a huge mistake.
Now, if you're not,
I've been watching a bunch of you.
A bunch of you have been dopes.
You're not educated
and you're buying the
wrong grading companies,
you're buying the wrong grades,
you're buying the wrong
actual rookie card.
Get educated for 25 to 50 hours,
then start purchasing.
Not 'cause Gary Vee said buy sports cards,
you just buy random shit.
Some people are going to garage sales
buying $50 worth of
cards worth four cents.
Four fucking cents.
- [Female] How many
times have you been hit
by those elevator doors, Gary?
Have a good night.
- You guys,
you stink, there's fire there,
you don't know how to title
and I'm fucking,
I stink 'cause I don't now how to title
because I don't title.
We missed that.
Wine texts is not doing well
without me running it.
- [Drock] You want to title?
- Yeah, I think I'm
better than all of you.
- [Drock] Maybe I'll just stop.
- Unless I can schedule
time to sit down and do it,
I haven't been able to perform.
And now that all my trips are canceled,
I'm not doing anything.
Without a plane, I'm not functional.
So are you buying sports cards?
(laughing)
Everybody out.
The concept is I'm gonna talk about
how unbelievable I am
at being okay with dropping balls.
So you're gonna go tttttt.
I'm just gonna throw 'em all
up and try to catch them.
You're gonna say go
and I'm gonna go.
Drock, can we make sure
that when we use not me in the content
that we don't use your hand?
'Cause your weird thumb
is fucking my brand up.
- [Drock] Oh my God.
(laughing)
Yes, Gary.
- Thank you, Drock.
(laughing)
He's got a weird thumb.
He's got a beautiful face.
I wish I had his face.
No, I like your face.
I think you're a handsome dude.
John, you like his face?
- [John] I think he's a good looking guy.
- I do too.
People low key really think Drock's hot.
- [John] I don't sleep anymore.
You should see him.
- [Male] They come in the bar
and just take the photo.
- But you know what that is,
that's just clout on me.
He's winning on, it really pisses me off,
completely leveraging my clout, Drock.
I went there because I'm plotting.
- I just wanted to know.
I used to go there back in the day.
I cleaned up the falls a little bit.
- I'm a plotta.
Should I be a plotta, P-L-O-T-T-A?
What is Gary up to?
I'm not an entrepreneur, I'm a plotta.
There might be,
this is literally why we document
because my brain just
went to 13 years from now
that being a term.
- The Instagram model.
- Hey guys, I don't think
I'm an entrepreneur anymore.
(laughing)
♪ Y'all be on some hard shit ♪
♪ I just do my own shit ♪